oi oi oi oi
o fatos pessoal daqui quem fala da arca
já fazia muito tempo que não trazia
vídeos aqui para o canal principal para
os Canario também não mas isso pronto
interessa todo por conta da depressão
pós quarentena operei quarentena é bom
mas eu fui a psicóloga e ele ensinou a
dizer no meu nome em japonês Dark frame
em Japonês é para tu com uma pessoa O
que é que nós vamos fazer hoje hoje nós
vamos jogar aquele joguinho famoso assim
eu vou ser sincero eu joguei uma ou duas
vezes o jogo original Mas hoje nós vamos
jogar umas profissões alternativas de
longa amongas mundo é
E aí
eu estou me foi recomendado por ninguém
e tem Russo Depois de meses tem fazer
vídeo eu trago desisto a bom Tá OK Tá
aqui o jogo amor esse ponto é Bora Boo é
que tá tocar a pantera cor-de-rosa não
tem nada a ver e imprimir postar porque
estava este jogo se eu não gostar eu já
não gosto não tá aí de James e consigo
mexer o boneco Não lembro nem sabe Ok
pelo menos isso olha que ver o jogo em
pé ninguém só que sempre eu sempre ficar
o demônio aqui ó
O alho shift podiam ter dito podia ter
instruções x dá para soltar Ok olha aí
jogo por cadarço cadarço Olha aí mas
Dark frame sempre lá ok fácil esta
música dá-me Vontade de ter uma manga no
meu cu Ah não assim tá chato né olha
habilidade Olha aí vamos sim que sou
louca
é tão Calma daqui tá muito exaltado só a
trocar eu faço uso como é que eu vou
jogar jogos que ninguém recomendou é
assim vida de Antônio Ramos aquilo
também cai não sou eu percebo que eu
tenho disfunção motora que eu é porque
eu não estou conseguir saltar não sabe
2020 a minha filha tá a y u
e ele deve calçar o que o 47 a unha toca
a unha dele impossível porque é que eu
venho jogar estas coisas porque qualquer
pessoa se quiser experimentar este jogo
o link está na descrição tá aí só quem
um vírus uma ameaça foi detectada para
mesmo que isso aconteça porque assim
vocês estão a salvo deste jogo mas eu
duvido que vocês passem mais do que eu
olha aí olha aí então o mestre eu tô ai
ai aqui no meio eu quem inventou este
jogo a mãe dela deveria ser Olha que é
porque isto é de uma pessoa normal meu
isso tem que ser um psicopata que joga
joga Roblox se God of War ao mesmo tempo
com os pés só pode vir de uma pessoa
assim
a injeção de QI injeção de Caim chinês
agora agora eu só começa importante
a mulher latika masaya o não o que eu
pensei que uma plataforma por cima este
jogo gera avc's em pessoas olha salto
macabro
[Música]
é só se quiserem ver mais vídeos de
jogos passa lá no meu canal de jogos Ok
eu não vou gostar sempre jogos aqui mas
com a quarentena é o que tem que ser né
porque eu não consigo fazer coisas lá
fora também e a maioria das ideias que
eu quero eu sou burro meio das ideias
que eu quero fazer que nós posso fazer
agora então por enquanto eu posso faltar
assim uns vídeos aleatórios Espero que
gostem
E aí
eu nunca passei daqui o meu Deus a
música tá intensificar uou é moleque Oh
Tu viu que uma travadinha e agora
E aí
como conseguir o meu Deus é
e eu não estou a perceber Isto é só
parado [ __ ] canta funk vai lá
pessoal próximo jogo título desconhecido
não tem nome só tem start game e
supostamente é um jogo de ação em 3D
desta vez é triste Ok temos o sol e
temos aqui o mangá verde é o alongado
que se não é o boneco deves ter tipo
farmácia depois disso tem qualquer coisa
ali andar alguém naquela cama ali ó
o botãozinho vamos começar é preparar
uma mil que ele vai arrepiar eu já sei
já Olha lá temos uma chave de chave de
porcas aprendi olha aí Aurélio biliar
está perfeita temos aqui um belo
exemplar de um osso ou se maligno Será
que ele já para eu ir em frente eu vou
tentar já ir em frente que ele parece
uma armadilha não sei por que mexer bem
algo vai saltar aqui de esquerdo e
e depois desta tudo preparado estou
preparado para tudo bem Um banho banho
banho a mão grandes bem não existe senti
uma sai sentir um um obsessor empurraram
aqui que também o tio se publica alguma
coisa empurra aqui para dizer
e quando olhei Oi tem alguém aqui uma
caixa por isso eu dou aqui vermelho azul
não não é que ele é muito gordo consigo
azul não sei se vocês estão perceber mas
é eu estou perdido Olha a
a porta de metal faz tudo pedra muito
bem vocês conseguiram fazer este jogo
conseguir abrir esta porta
é a que maravilha gosta de jogo Final
gostou tem lhe Pronto já sei que vai dar
temos Cars vamos procurar a nossa cueca
pessoal já sabem Aumente o volume ao
menos em o saldo de uma preparar para o
susto já sabem que eu já Ai Olha está de
costas para mim ó ai ai não posso passar
Olha eu tô perdido.na
a hora que eu consegui vulgar o jugo
a porta forró o o a Terra é plana fique
um botão Calma vou aproveitar que ele
está de costas preciso carregar aqui eu
não sei eu não percebo eu não percebo
este jogo que é que o momento neste
jogos por quê Porque eu não me joga um
lol porque eu não jogo o celular um
fortnite bons jogos não é não me
convence não está com vencer este jogo
salto estavas a convencer este jogo não
ficar um bom five Nights at freddy's já
agora comentem aí pessoal se vale a pena
comprar a PlayStation 5 só para jogar
fortnite cometem eu vou comprar ou calmo
então às vezes atrás mesmo ele nem sabe
descer a escada bem por quem tem estou
na cápsula eu sou interstellar não
aconteceu nada aconteceu alguma coisa
ativei o botão vermelho ainda estou
preso a gente aqui uma porta aqui ó
[Música]
a pulseira produzir Live ajuste para mim
eu estou ficar ereto que eu poste podre
mas assustou assustou Assustou é um
facto mas estou acusam
eu posso apanhar esta pistola até que é
um free fez o Leon a
a roupa bate fecha para lá aí mesmo vem
já morre cara
e ficou de pé e a mão Phillips ela não é
isso aí moleque obrigou a outra vez
manda aí
[Música]
eu estou eu mandei o print só certinho o
estado já sabem deixem muito like aqui
nesse vídeo Se quiserem partilhem com os
vossos amigos no WhatsApp é importante
que seja lá no WhatsApp toda a gente tem
WhatsApp e é isso pessoal fiquem bem e
até a próxima a
[Música]
E aí